[Music]
okay so you guys are collaborating yeah
we just drop liquor daya laughs it's so
exciting
we literally like when in the studio one
night like fell asleep in mystery I woke
up with like a banger and then we were
like we got to get one out like within
the next week so we both never die and I
put it out then it's like the reactions
amazing
everybody loves the chemistry you're not
I mean like it just works you know a lot
of feelings right okay so he's my best
friend but it's nice I would think that
when you've grown up in such a famous
family know like to have someone that
really loves you so I go for this
adventure well yeah I mean I think also
like I was just talking to something I
was like it's hard when no one
understands like the time zones and like
the schedule and no one really
understands that more than him and we've
been crying in our rooms together
forever like about how this we're like
exhausted together and like it's cool to
find somebody that like understands that
[Music]